Trascrizione:
Come vi immaginate un carcere minorile?
Immagino che la maggior parte di voi
non ci sia mai stato.
Vi ci provo a portare io,
con l'immaginazione quantomeno.
C'è una parte del carcere minorile
che è esattamente come ce la immaginiamo.
Quindi ci sono le sbarre,
ci sono i blindi,
ci sono le serrature,
c'è lo spioncino pure al cesso,
c'è il pavimento
di quella graniglia brutta.
Ci sono le pareti di cemento
ridipinte, ridipinte,
di quei colori scialbi,
così tante volte
che sembra felpato, il cemento,
però vi assicuro
che non è felpato, assolutamente.
C'è una parte del carcere
che è esattamente quella
che conosciamo, che ci immaginiamo,
e vi assicuro che è la parte
che fa meno paura.
Adesso venite con me nei corridoi,
provate a chiudere gli occhi
e ad annusare, annusare,
annusare, annusare.
La sentite questa puzza
complessa, stratificata?
Vi aiuto a decodificarla.
C'è disinfettante
industriale, sicuramente.
C'è una puzza di sudore
che potrebbe ricordare quella
delle palestre, dei campionati giovanili;
però senza quel brivido bello
di... speranza.
Shampoo forse sì, ma non balsamo;
deodorante forse sì,
ma non acqua di colonia.
E poi c'è la puzza della paura.
Ecco, la puzza della paura
non ve la so descrivere,
se non dicendovi che sa un po' di...
Primordiale.
Ok, adesso chiudete gli occhi,
continuate a tenerli chiusi
e chiudete il naso, se ci riuscite.
Ascoltiamo:
la chiave, la chiave
bella pesante, quella d'ottone,
gira nel blindo: ta-lac!
Non tlac: ta-lac.
C'è metallo dovunque, in carcere:
si sente il metallo,
metallo scosso, metallo bussato,
metallo percosso, metallo strisciato;
e poi, di nuovo,
la chiave gira nel blindo: ta-lac.
E poi ci sono i silenzi, in carcere.
I silenzi sono la parte
più difficile da raccontarvi.
I silenzi sono delle enormi
parentesi graffe
dove dentro c'è la rabbia,
la frustrazione, i dubbi
e ovviamente, ancora una volta, la paura.
Io sono dieci anni
che provo a farmi spazio
in queste parentesi graffe di silenzio
con i miei laboratori,
nelle carceri minorili,
di rap e di poesia.
Ogni volta che ne comincio uno,
c'è sempre la stessa scena.
C'è un ragazzo che sta
in disparte agli altri, no?
Dandosi l'aria da ultracriminale,
mi guarda così,
come a dire, "Non me ne fotte
un cazzo di te".
Che già questo sarebbe discutibile,
perché la partecipazione
ai miei laboratori è volontaria,
quindi se non te ne fotte un cazzo di me
te ne potevi stare in cella,
e il problema era risolto.
Comunque, io non dico niente,
lui non dice niente, e andiamo avanti.
Aspetta la pausa sigaretta,
perché in carcere fumano tutti.
Durante la pausa sigaretta - io non fumo -
mi si avvicina con l'aria
di chi mi vuole dare una coltellata.
Per fortuna la coltellata che mi dà
è una coltellata di parole,
occhio che è una parola unica, mi fa:
"Mi aiuti a scrivere una canzone
per la mia fidanzata
che mi aspetta fuori?"
E poi aggiunge, "Però
non lo deve sapere nessuno".
E io chiaramente sorrido
e prometto omertà.
Ecco, vorrei prendere
l'occasione di questo palco
per ringraziare pubblicamente
tutte le fidanzate, o presunte tali,
dei ragazzi in carcere,
per avermi dato il modo
di bucare la rabbia,
la frustrazione, la diffidenza
rese ancora più granitiche
dal blindo e dalle sbarre alla finestra.
Quindi che cosa succede?
Io dico a questo ragazzo,
"Ok, io ti aiuto, ma tu devi aiutare me.
Dimmi qualcosa, di questa ragazza".
E lui mi dice, "Eh, è bellissima".
Per cui, "Ok, è bellissima:
ma quando vi siete conosciuti?
Che tempo faceva?
Dove vi siete dati il primo bacio?
Cosa ti aspetti da qua,
due anni a cinque anni, con lei?"
Ecco, a questo punto,
se io sono stato abbastanza bravo
nell'accendere la miccia,
la magia è fatta.
Mi basta aiutare un po' questo ragazzo
con la metrica, con le rime,
e la creatività viene fuori.
Bruce Lee diceva:
"Io non faccio esperienza,
io sono esperienza".
Ecco, negli ultimi anni
io ho deciso che voglio provare
a non fare hip hop,
ma ad essere hip hop.
E il carcere puzza di hip hop esattamente
come puzza di disinfettante industriale.
Molte delle canzoni
che vi piacciono e conoscete,
a partire da 2pac,
sono state scritte in carcere.
E lasciando perdere i giganti, come 2pac,
in questo esatto momento,
in carcere ci sono dei ragazzi
che scrivono con la penna
sul foglio delle rime,
magari seguendo i consigli
che gli ha dato uno scemo come me
durante il laboratorio.
Il grande regalo che mi hanno
fatto questi ragazzi,
la grande opportunità che mi hanno dato,
è stata quella di affrontare
il processo creativo
esattamente come loro,
Ficcare le mani dentro il gomitolo
di caos che abbiamo dentro,
il gomitolo di rabbia, frustrazione,
debolezza, fragilità, indifferenza,
e provare a tirare un filo,
e vedere dove mi porta questo filo.
Vedere se mi porta fuori
o ancora più dentro al gomitolo.
Vedere se lo scioglie, il gomitolo,
o vedere se il filo, piano piano,
si stringe ancora più forte
intorno alle mie mani,
come due manette.
Ci sono delle catene fisiche, ovviamente;
in carcere è drammaticamente attuale.
Ci sono delle catene fisiche
delle quali è molto difficile liberarsi;
ma anche con delle catene fisiche ai polsi
esistono dei grimaldelli,
dei piedi di porco, dei cacciaviti
che ci aiutano a liberarci, quanto meno,
delle nostre catene mentali.
Grazie a quei ragazzi,
io ho scritto un libro
che non credevo di poter scrivere;
e molte canzoni che non credevo
di poter scrivere,
fino a quando mi sono reso conto
che ero io a vietarlo a me stesso.
E voi, specialmente voi ragazzi,
che cosa vi vietate di fare?
Quali sono le realtà
che nella vostra vita non funzionano,
e che non mettete in discussione
perché vi è stato detto
che non si possono mettere in discussione,
o peggio ancora,
perché siete stati voi a dirvi
che non potete metterle in discussione?
Angela Davis, una rivoluzionaria
statunitense afroamericana,
ha detto: "Non voglio più accettare
ciò che non si può cambiare.
Voglio cambiare
ciò che non si può accettare".
Cosa - tutti, non solo i ragazzi, tutti:
cosa siamo disposti a non accettare più
nella nostra realtà,
in cui comunichiamo,
nel modo in cui ci rapportiamo,
con una società che, ancora nel 2021,
tiene ragazzi e ragazze
minorenni, adolescenti,
rinchiusi dietro sbarre fisiche e mentali?
Cosa siamo disposti a fare per cambiarlo?
Ogni volta che inizio
un laboratorio in carcere,
la prima cosa che faccio
è chiedere ai ragazzi:
come vi sentite?
E in carcere, chiaramente,
non mi possono rispondere: mi sento bene.
Quindi mi rispondono con due parole,
le due parole sono:
boh, virgola, normale, punto.
E io ci rimango male, anche se non dovrei,
perché me lo dovrei aspettare,
perché la risposta, "Boh, normale",
significa che il gomitolo
di cui vi parlavo prima
è ancora stretto.
Ma quando...
nel prosieguo del laboratorio riusciamo
ad allargarlo un po', il gomitolo,
cambiano anche le risposte
a "Come ti senti?".
Mi sento dire: io oggi mi sento triste,
io oggi mi sento annoiato,
oggi mi sento che vorrei spaccare tutto,
oggi mi sento che vorrei uscire
e fare un concerto con te,
appena esco.
Ecco: ogni giorno, chiedermi cosa sento
e come mi sento,
ogni giorno provare ad ascoltarmi,
ogni volta che è possibile, rispondermi,
e poi di nuovo chiedermi
cosa sento e come mi sento.
E a quel punto, magari,
provare a stabilire un ponte
tra me e i miei simili.
Non tutti voi farete gli scrittori,
e per fortuna non tutti voi
farete i rapper.
Ma non fatevi mai togliere
il privilegio di creare,
il privilegio di ficcare
la mano dentro il gomitolo,
anche senza dover pubblicare,
anche senza raccontarlo ad altri,
anche solo per voi stessi.
Questo è il gomitolo sciolto,
questa è la creatività nata dal caos.
E a conclusione del mio intervento,
vi vorrei far sentire
un po' di versi che ho scritto,
che parlano più o meno di questa cosa.
Fanno così.
Qui niente che cambi col tempo, distanti,
capendoci meno e parlando di più,
e sono sincero,
mi sembra che il cielo stasera
abbia un tono sbagliato di blu.
Vorrei bruciare le foto ricordo,
il diario di bordo, la vela e il timone,
decostruire quell'ansia sottile
che nelle mie rime
rivela il tuo nome.
Se mi togliessi le gioie più intense,
le nubi dense di assenze che accuso,
ciò che mi manca e ciò che mi stanca,
resterebbe un residuo confuso.
Fossi poeta avrei dossi e difese,
gli ossi di seppia, il flow di Pavese,
ma mi s'inceppa la penna appena s'accenna
che in casa non c'è Sangiovese.
Fossi cantante avrei voce importante,
fossi politico, un titolo in sé,
fossi brigante gridavo "Adelante!",
chiedendo in prestito un sigaro al Che.
Fossi chi sono terrei questo suono
al sicuro, nell'incavo scuro dei palmi,
restituendolo al vento solo un momento.
È tempo di addormentarmi.
Inchiostro, accompagna e condanna
a faccia di mostro e braccia di mamma,
la noia che telecomanda
ci priva del nostro
e al suo posto da dramma.
I sogni hanno gli occhi di tigri,
e vecchie canzoni, prigioni e ospedale,
il tempo è dei giorni che passano pigri
e lasciano in bocca il gusto del male.
Il niente che ascolta
ora chiede risposta alla mente,
che non se n'è accorta.
Le note lo sanno, non stanno cambiando
fin quando non cambio a mia volta.
Sfocando i contorni del tempo
stanno nei dintorni, sfidando nei giorni.
E l'ansia non passa,
l'alba non calma, si campa
aspettando che torni.
Finendo il bicchiere nel buio
non vedo che il vino trabocca dall'orlo.
Autocontrollo,
ma l'oggi m'avvolge
una sciarpa di dubbi sul collo.
Vorrei che domani arrivasse,
svuotarvi le tasche,
strapparvi le maschere,
musica soul nelle casse.
Se solo accadesse, potreste rinascere.
Ma qui l'infinito è sparito
e l'eco si è persa dentro l'alfabeto,
come facessi un graffito col dito
sulla condensa del vetro.
Il tempo che passa distante
mi allena e mi lega, gassa d'amante,
silenzi sovrastano e non mi basta
un flow di adamantio e diamante.
Volare sulle ali del mistral,
i dorsi dei libri, da equilibrista,
stressandomi meno e coprendo il terreno,
boxando con l'io nichilista.
Freddo di liquido azoto
tra brivido e fuoco:
e io ancora che parlo.
Niente che riempia quel vuoto,
ci metto quel poco
che possa arginarlo. Grazie.